now joining us to explain more about
last night's elections and what it means
for biden's agenda going forward senator
marco rubio senator i was intrigued by
senator manchin's comments as he said i
told you so without saying it quite that
way yeah it's interesting you know for
364 days a year these people who run all
these major corporations in the media
and a lot of government all the far left
people
they they spend their time using their
power to tell us what to think what
we're allowed to say what we're allowed
to do but there's one day every year or
every two years where the normal people
get to speak and that's called election
day and that's what you saw yesterday
it's parents who during last parents
when normal people get to speak not not
the elected officials and not the people
on tv and radio right i agree but that's
the dividing line in politics today the
dividing line isn't even left to right
anymore it's crazy versus normal it's
it's parents it's these people that run
our school systems and so forth and and
parents who over the during the pandemic
for the first time got to see what their
kids were learning because they were
learning from home and they're like
you're learning what they're teaching
you what and then when they spoke up now
they're domestic terrorists and look i
watched with great interest all this
coverage about white supremacists in
virginia last night as you pointed out a
jamaican immigrant african-american
woman was elected to the lieutenant
governor of the state a cuban-american
jason miyares was elected attorney
general of the state of the commonwealth
of virginia none of that's being
reported these people are nuts they
spend all day on television and and
after after they're off the air talking
to everybody and they all agree with
each other because they all live in one
or two cities and they they literally
are completely out of touch with the
fact that 97 of the american population
lives completely different lives has
completely different views and then when
they when election day comes they can't
explain it so they chalk it up to they
cheated or white supremacist or whatever
they make something because they can't
comprehend it last night was the
beginning of that pushback and i think
it's going to continue and you ask about
the agenda here it's the craziest thing
i've ever seen it's these people are
governing like they have a mandate to
radically remake the country it's build
back socialism it doesn't matter if it's
1.75 trillion or 3.5 trillion they want
to take control of pre-k of child care
the only two elements of education they
don't control now they want to take
control of that they want to hire 80 000
irs agents so the pushback is only going
to grow and and this administration by
the way has been disastrous on
everything whether it's afghanistan now
it's russia threatening to invade
ukraine taiwan supply chains and
they can't name you a single thing that
joe biden has managed correctly in his
first nine or ten months as president
they can't name you one
i i gave my list of what i think needs
the the path that the country needs to
follow conservative principles that work
for reagan they work for president trump
they work for newt gingrich in the
contract with america
i would like
2022
to be
a referendum election and i want every
republican to put a signature on a paper
that says they pledge to do those things
if they get elected that far-fetched
idea too gimmicky what are your thoughts
no and by the way we were doing a lot of
those things when donald trump was in
the white house and then these guys have
come in and they've basically tried to
reverse everything even the things that
made sense they reversed it they stopped
the border wall which is popular
everybody understands we need to have
something like that in this country and
we now have tons of steel and brick wall
components sitting there rotting stuff
already been paid for by the american
taxpayer they have this
deranged obsession against putting the
wall up you talk about returning
manufacturing you know if we made more
things in america we wouldn't have a
supply chain crisis or at least the
serious is the one that we have right
now uh so some of those things are
already happening these guys get in they
take control the house the senate the
white house and they begin to reverse
all the things that make sense and today
we're a country that isn't producing
energy domestically but is begging all
these other countries around the world
to produce more oil even while we don't
produce our own i mean this is crazy
if i had described this to anybody two
years ago they would have said that's
never going to happen i mean the other
guys aren't that crazy yes they are
yeah no they they really they really are
that crazy i mean uh but the sad part is
the damage that they're doing is also
real senator uh one year from now you
will be up for re-election and when you
look at the senate map and the it will
be one bellwether state for republicans
after another and that's an important
race we'll be following and supporting
your candidacy down in florida thanks
for being with us hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else